muy buenos días pues espera que la
sesión comience dentro de unas pocas
horas y el voto cede sobre finales de la
tarde de este martes aquí en parís es un
texto que ha dividido muchísimo al
parlamento ya se sabe por ejemplo que el
partido socialista va a abstenerse de
votar que 'francia insumisa para su
partido de izquierda y también
reagrupación nacional la extrema derecha
votarán en contra pero es muy posible
que el texto finalmente sea aprobado ya
que la mayoría va a votar a favor la
verdad quienes se oponen a este texto de
ley han dicho que finalmente es un texto
que no aporta ningún tipo de solución a
los problemas precisamente para que
sigan proliferando este tipo de
discursos que separan a la nación pero
lo más probable es que ese texto sea
aprobado y luego pasará ya a voto en el
senado en el mes de marzo natalia usted
lo menciona hay divisiones al interior
de la asamblea pero también en la
sociedad francesa que es lo que
contempla entonces este proyecto de ley
que ha generado rechazo por algunos
sectores como los defensores de las
libertades individuales y también de los
derechos humanos hay mucha polémica allí
así es hay unos artículos bastante
controvertidos el primero de ellos es el
que más el debate de género debate
bastante intenso fue en torno a la
educación en casa algo que de manuel
mccone quería prohibir pero el
parlamento no siguió por esta línea a
pesar de que era una manera según el
presidente de que se pudieran evitar la
proliferación de más escuelas digamos
que en las que haya discursos radicales
en todo caso la puerta sigue abierta
para este tipo de educación pero tendrán
que tener el aval del ministerio de
educación en nacionales algunas
derogaciones como por ejemplo prácticas
culturales artísticas o motivos de salud
otro de los puntos allí es la creación
de un nuevo delito cuando se difunda
informaciones personales de una persona
y que esto ponga en riesgo la vida de la
persona estas digamos para luchar contra
el odio en internet se ha creado este
delito 45 mil euros de multa tres hasta
tres años de cárcel y el último es uno
de los puntos más álgidos qué tiene que
ver con la regulación de las
asociaciones de culto la mayoría de las
iglesias de las mezquitas las
congregaciones funcionan
este bajo esta figura y lo que quiere el
estado finalmente se controlar aún más
la financiación de estos de estas
asociaciones quienes están detrás de
estas asociaciones sobre todo cuando
piden subsidios por parte del estado en
realidad los representantes de los
diferentes cultos aquí en el país han
dicho que creen que es una ley demasiado
represiva y que incluso puede tener
efectos son contraproducentes